mes chers amis merci d'être là aussi
nombreux
un salut particulier à ceux qui sont
dans la salle d'en bas parce que parce
que vous étiez si nombreux que c'était
difficile accueillir tout le monde
dans celle ci et par votre nom vous
témoigner de la forte mobilisation de la
fédé de paris autour de sa nouvelle
équipe
c'est un bonheur particulier que de
tenir cette réunion dans ses locaux qui
témoigne d'une certaine forme de
résistance la résistance face à la
médiocrité de françois hollande
puisqu'ici on prépare à l'alternance
pour 2017 il n'y a pas une semaine sans
qu'il y ait une journée de réflexion de
travail des journées dans lesquelles la
fédération de paris est très souvent
très bien représentée merci à tous ceux
qui participent à ces travaux
et puis ça symbolise la résistance aussi
la résistance à l'idéologie à la
démagogie de la ville de paris puisque
le mur de berlin est tombé en 1989
mais certains élus de paris sont restés
bloqués au millénaire précédent
le sinistre ian brossât qu'évoquait tout
à l'heure claude goasguen et anne
hidalgo ont voulu présenter cet immeuble
pour y mettre des logements sociaux
ce matin nous leur envoyons le message
que la place est occupée est bien occupé
merci à vous
je suis heureuse d'être ce matin aux
côtés de philippe qui fait un travail
formidable à la tête de la fédé a la
chance de travailler avec lui tous les
jours à l'assemblée nationale à l'hôtel
de ville
il ya des gens qu'on apprécie toujours
plus avec le temps et puis au contraire
il y en a d'autres qui perdent à être
connu l'analyse des résultats électoraux
dans le 15e arrondissement classe sans
ambiguïté philippe d'un côté et anne
hidalgo de l'autre à chaque élection
philippe améliore son score philippe ça
va devenir gênant et ils infligent une
raclée plus en plus sévères à anne
hidalgo qui l'a battu à plus de 60% en
général à ce moment là d'une secours tu
réagis étudie 65 mais 63 et encore il a
failli passer au premier tour
du coup d'ailleurs la mère de pareil a
eu tellement peur de ne pas aller au
second tour quelle en est réduite à
appeler le gouvernement à l'aide pour
redécouper les arrondissements ben
voyons au camp il ya de la gêne y'a pas
de plaisir à notre président de fédé il
manquait qu'un secrétaire départemental
c'est chose faite avec frédéric je suis
sûr que pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient
pas encore bien vous apprendrez tous à
aimer frédéric comme nous mêmes on a
appris à l'aimer dans la campagne de
paris frédéric c'est un double bonheur
d'abord c'est l'assurance que le travail
est bien fait une assurance qui
appréciaient jusqu en très haut lieu
cher nicolas on le sait et puis c'est le
plaisir de le faire en équipe et quand
on a un coût nous on peut toujours lui
demander une histoire de sa jeunesse
policière et c'est mieux qu'un roman
huguet bénédicte aurore nicolas il
faudrait citer tous ceux qui prolongent
autour de lui l'engagement et l'esprit
de la campagne de paris philippe et
frédéric savent choisir leur équipe et
je suis heureuse que dans la campagne on
n'est plus pour certains faire pépinière
et puis à propos de pépinières il
faudrait citer dans la salle tous les
élus tous les militants qui se mobilise
au quotidien les militants se sera pas
possible mais les élus je voudrais quand
même traversé balayé les arrondissements
cité dans le premier jean françois
legaret son maire et nicolas martin
lalande qui a rejoint son équipe
frédéric dans le deuxième je crois bien
christophe qui est discret et là quelque
part j'ai vu passer un tweet dans le 3è
benoît solès dans le quatrième cu tation
très spécial à vincent roger qui s'est
fait voler la victoire de peu et qui
continuent à se battre grâce à vous tous
dans le 5ème florence a dû passer tout à
l'heure dans le 6e jean pierre lecoq
votre maire a pris la parole il a
accompagné ce matin par alexandre
vesperini notre notre junior notre plus
jeune le plus jeune du conseil de paris
on le rappelle régulièrement
dans le 7e j'ai vu emmanuelle dauvergne
qui est ici avec nous dans le viiième
catherine l'écuyer qui est aussi nicolas
présente dans ton équipe comme
secrétaire nationale tous les mercredis
de la commission exécutive et pierre
lellouche
mais je suis très les parlementaires
aussi par ailleurs dans le 9ème delphine
bürkli et elle a tout à l'heure et elle
est représentée de manière permanente
par jean baptiste de froment dont le jeu
c'est nicolas tu apprécies aussi les
travaux dans le xème delphine vie
déborah qui a rejoint en plus l'équipe
que présentait frédéric tout à l'heure
dans le xième aurore frédéric elle est
maintenant à tes côtés
tous les jours mais maintenant aussi
christian qui a su traverser la ligne et
nous rejoindre et on apprécie sa
présence en bronze dans le xiième
valérie avec laquelle on travaille bien
dans le xiiième je n'ai pas vu je sais
qu'ils sont pas loin dans le 14ème un
salut particulier à mon équipe qui met
quotidiennement a servi la
circonscription au tour de bertrand le
st adam 15 je sais pas si on peut tous
les citer philippe tellement hisse au
800 nombreux mais quand même il ya
daniel georges qui est là si daniel
georges pour tout ce que tu fais à nier
c'est vrai qu'en plus des porte parole
de la campagne claire mais clermont
tonnerre je vais rater je sais j'en rate
et pascal qui est là sylvie pascale
bayet chassaigne sylvie sirach wii qui
j'oublie comment ben alors jean françois
lamour je vais le citer parmi les
parlementaires je me suis engagé je le
sens dans une campagne difficile
non mais je finis quand même parce que
c'est important ils sont tous là et ils
se battent au quotidien pour vous 16e il
y avait claude qui étaient là tout à
l'heure mais à julie aussi qui a rejoint
l'équipe il ya céline qui est là et à
jérémy qui est lui aussi présent dans
l'équipe il ya pierre gaboriaud qui
notre trésorier au groupe mais on sait
que c'est quand même voilà et on
apprécie et dans le 17 l'équipe est
quasiment au complet autour de brigitte
là où s'ils sont nombreux autour de
frédéric ya geoffroy qui qui donne un
beau coup de main et à jérôme du bus qui
vous a parlé tout à l'heure sur la
question du logement dont il constitue
un bon et un grand spécialiste ya
catherine dumas merci catherine être
présente dans le 18e
puis arriva été abondamment cité il le
sera à nouveau tout à l'heure le 19e
avec jean jacques et le 20e avec la
canine
merci nathalie d'être présente aussi il
ya quelques extra territoriaux pierre
mais oui pierre tu étais pas cité dans
le xvème parce que les sénateurs toi tu
plane au dessus de paris ainsi que
philippe qui au premier rang philippe
dominati
merci merci m avec avec ses avec ses 25
mille adhérents la fédération de paris
va jouer un rôle déterminant dans les
prochaines élections et à ya les
régionales qui a j'oubliai quelqu'un
bénédicte c'est ça c'est sûr forcément
oui bah écoute oui mais j'avais
d'exciter les élus les élus les élus
conseillers paille sinon je m'en sors
pas les régions est et le laboratoire du
hollandisme enoch l'alternance ça
commence par les régionales et avec
valérie qui nie tout à l'heure nous
diffuser beaucoup d'énergie au tour de
pierre yves sur lequel j'ai la chance de
pouvoir compter au conseil de paris on
est tous on sera tous pendant toute
cette campagne très mobilisés moi
j'espère juste qu'ils arrivent que quand
valérie sera président de la région
ile-de-france est laissera du temps pour
te consacrer au groupe républicain de
paris où tu es un allié fidèle comme
jean-françois legaret vous savez on
reconnaît au conseil de paris les bons
au silence angoissé de la gauche quand
ils prennent la parole
ils attendent à gauche
la baffe avec jean françois et avec
pierre et ils n'attendent pas longtemps
elle vient vite et puis après les
régionales ou en même temps parce que ça
va se faire en même temps il ya la
métropole du grand paris la gauche a
voulu rétropédaler sur ce projet quand
elle a vu qu'elle avait perdu la
majorité c'est élégant
puis elle a voulu trafic et le scrutin
pour éloigner certains candidats ou
certaines candidates qui n'avaient pas
la chance de lui plaire et qui
d'ailleurs n'essaye pas et aujourd'hui
elle prétend choisir parmi les nôtres ça
c'est le pompon la métropole de paris
c'est une institution un peu bancal qui
se met en place
on peut avoir la nostalgie cher nicolas
des premier grand discours fondateur sur
le grand paris et notamment le discours
du palais de chaillot et du concours
d'architecte que tu avais lancé
c'était quand même autre chose ça avait
une autre gueule mais enfin ce qui est
là et là il faudra remettre l'ouvragé
sur le métier en 2017 en attendant on va
essayer de faire oeuvre utile
j'ai évoqué la date fatidique 2017
la fédération de paris jouera un rôle
essentiel pour ces échéances
cette échéance que nous attendons avec
le plus d'impatience puisqu'elle ce
point enfin c'est celle qui pourra enfin
mettre un terme au mandat de françois
hollande pouvoir socialiste est
tellement vacances c'est ainsi qu'on
pourrait se demander s'il vit encore
françois hollande n'apparaît plus que
pour participer à des sommets à
l'étranger ou dans des documentaires
télévisés insipide sur l'exercice du
pouvoir
il engage plus de réforme d'envergure de
peur de rencontrer la division de sa
propre majorité
mais enfin le plus grand danger face à
un pouvoir fantômes se serait pensé que
la partie serait facile
rien ne serait plus faux nous préparons
l'alternance c'est nous la préparons
dans un parti refonder nouveau mouvement
nouveau statut nouvelle gouvernance
autant de preuves de notre mur qui vont
s'illustrer dans les deux prochaines
années
en janvier prochain nous élirons
démocratiquement au suffrage universel
nos présidents de fédérations ça se
passera le samedi 30 janvier à la fédé
paris c'est une première dans l'histoire
de notre parti
nicolas tu m'avais confié cette réforme
des statuts elle est à l'honneur de
notre famille politique ne devons pas
sous-estimer ce grand moment
démocratique
puis après il y aura la primaire nous
avons pu l'expérimenter à paris je salue
encore une fois mes anciens concurrents
on est la preuve vivante dans l'équipe
conforme aujourd'hui que ça peut aussi
se passait bien
pas pour la présidentielle à droite ce
sera une première une épreuve autant
qu'une preuve de notre mutation à nous
d'en faire un vrai succès populaire
voilà je finis avec un mot spécial aux
militants pour vous dire que vous êtes
vous au coeur de ces changements
c'est vous qui voteraient pour le
président de la fédé en janvier c'est
vous qui mobiliserait pour la primaire
pour son organisation faudra tenir les
bureaux de vote plus de 300 à paris
c'est vous qui vous exprimer semaine
après semaine sur internet pour choisir
les grandes options de notre programme
et tous ses nouveaux pouvoirs qui vous
ont été confiées à la suite de la
réforme des statuts qui avait engagé
nicolas tous ses nouveaux pouvoirs
c'est une reconnaissance c'est la
reconnaissance de si nous les élus nous
sommes la voix du parti et gars vous
autres les militants vous en êtes le
coeur battant c'est vous qui avait tenu
bon à l'automne 2012 quand on était la
risée des médias et quand le parti
trembler sur ses bases c'est vous qui
nous avez permis dans la campagne de
paris pour la première fois depuis
longtemps d'avoir plus de voix que la
gauche c'est vous qui ferait gagner
valérie et pierre-yves aux régionales
alors comme une simple militante je veux
vous dire merci du fond du coeur mais
aussi en avant